So one of the topics that we cover in
this class is optimization,
making a program faster but having it
compute the same result, and I like optimization a lot.
It is a lot of fun to think of
cool ways to speed up the code,
but it turns out that often getting the right answer
or maintaining the code later,
having the code be well documented,
making it easy to debug the code,
these things might all trump optimization.
Steve, have you seen anything like that in Mozilla
or other projects you've worked on?
[Steve] Constantly.
With the SpiderMonkey JavaScript engine these days,
I kind of feel like we spend half of our time removing old
optimizations to make way for refactoring; future engines.
I think we've been hit particularly hard
because we switched our JIT engines
several times at this point.
TraceMonkey was our original optimization--
well, our original JIT engine,
which had a particular style of optimization that it covered,
and we have since entirely removed
the TraceMonkey JIT engine and
replaced it with JägerMonkey,
which is kind of the next generation JIT engine,
except now, it's the previous generation
JIT engine itself, and it is slated to be
replaced by IonMonkey, we like monkeys.
>> I was going to there is referring monkey theme. [Steve] Yes.
And it turns out that the sorts of
optimizations that are really helpful
for a tracing style JIT
are really obnoxious when you get into
a different style of JIT, because they just get in the way,
and it prevents you from--you know--
making a lot of code simplifications that makes it
straight forward to do a JIT in a different style,
and so there are many, many different
optimizations that we've had to just rip out wholesale,
and unfortunately, it's at least as
much work to remove
some of these--some of these optimizations
as it was to make them in the first place,
and really anytime you do an optimization,
you have to be very aware of the cost of that optimization.
You may be saving some runtime,
but you are adding complexity to everybody who comes
by and tries to read and understand that code.
You are preventing some refactoring,
some restructurings of that code
because it would--
it would break the optimization--you know--
the optimization was made with certain assumptions,
that's almost the definition of an optimization is that
if we assume certain things,
then we don't have to do some of these operations,
and that's the way to make things faster is to
not do some of the things that you were previously doing.
And so there are all kinds of--you know--
hidden costs to an optimization,
and it can actually be very damaging to
put certain optimizations in the code
because they're going to prevent other optimizations,
they are going to prevent--you know--
simplifications of the code, they are going to prevent
changing the semantics of what you've implemented
because the optimization is based on certain
assumptions that you may want to change in the future,
and so we sent a lot of time--you know--
trying to find the right balance today,
which is actually different from the balance yesterday,
and so even if a previous optimization
made total sense in the past world,
it may actually get in the way in the current world.
So yeah, we see a lot of this.
>>Excellent, now you mentioned something
that caught my ear, and I wonder if I might put you on the
spot with a bit of a surprise question.
You mentioned that you're looking over old code and refactoring it,
and I'm just wondering throughout your average day,
let's say you spend some amount of time reading code
and some amount of time writing new code.
What's that ratio or how many hours is
fixing bugs and code, looking over old code,
and how much is writing new code?
[Steve] It varies a lot from day to day.
Some days are actually spent 100% writing new code,
and those days are happy days and rare days.
The vast majority really is looking at existing code,
sometimes code that I wrote,
much more often code that other people wrote,
and here at Mozilla, we have
a rule that every line of code that goes into the
tree must be reviewed by another person
so-you know--in terms of you have a
sealing of 50% of time is spent
on new code because every line of new
code is going to be viewed by at least one other person,
and often you'll go through multiple rounds of review,
and so--you know--multiple people or the same person
are looking at that line of code several times,
but even if you're going to write new code,
you always have to understand
the context in which you're placing that code,
and so you really have to understand what comes before,
and you will spend much, much of your time doing that,
far more of your time doing that
than kind of going into a green field
and putting something brand new in place.
>> And this idea that you have to understand
the context in which your adding code
is one of the reasons why understanding the meanings
of programs, their semantics, is so important.